mind your decisions a presh tallwalker
here
mark rober is one of the most popular
youtubers
he tweeted out for the last five months
every single video of mine has been
number one on youtube trending and
they're averaging 20 million views per
video
i have some thoughts on this
he was trying to put some perspective on
his fortune
in his explanation he had the following
sentence
if you give 1024 people a coin and give
them 10 tries to get as many tails as
possible it's a statistical certainty
that one of them will flip 10 tails in a
row
in the ensuing discussion people pointed
out the math on this wasn't entirely
correct
and mark admitted his mistake and they
got to the correct number
but for people who have never seen this
kind of calculation i thought it would
make for a good video
so
each of 1024 people flips a coin 10
times
what is the chance that at least one
person flips all 10 tails
next
suppose we repeat the experiment with n
people
how large must n be so there's a 99.9
chance that at least one person flips
all 10 tails
pause the video if you'd like to give
these problems a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these problems
[Music]
let's calculate the probability suppose
you flip a coin 10 times
each toss has a one-half chance to be
tails
the probability that you get ten tails
in a row will be equal to one-half
multiplied by one-half multiplied by
one-half a total of ten times
this simplifies to be one half to the
power of ten
we'll then consider the complement event
which is one minus this event
this will give you the probability that
you don't get ten tails in a row
now let's simplify this fraction and
then we're going to consider this event
for n people
each of n people has the same
probability so the probability that n
people don't get 10 tails will be this
probability raised to the power of n
we then consider the complement event
and that will be equal to the
probability that someone in n gets 10
tails
we'll now use this formula to solve both
parts
first we'll set n equal to 1024 which is
equal to 2 to the power of 10.
we substitute this in and we get the
following formula
we can actually estimate this without a
calculator
this term has the form 1 minus 1 over n
all raised to the power of n
if we take the limit as n goes to
infinity we get 1 over e which is
approximately 36.8 percent
we want 1 minus that so above will get
approximately 63.2 percent
it's nearly two out of three and that
ain't bad but it's not quite a
statistical certainty
so how large was nb to get to 99.9
percent
we'll set this equation equal to 99.9
percent
we'll then rearrange this equation and
simplify
we then take natural logs on both sides
and bring the exponent down
we then solve for n and then simplify to
get n is equal to 70 70 and some
fractional part
since n is a whole number we round up
we need at least
7071 people flipping coins to have a
99.9 chance that someone will get 10
tails in a row
i really enjoy problems like this and
i'm glad mark's tweet provided an
opportunity to cover this calculation
thanks for being the best subscribers on
youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]